How well do you remember your childhood,
rejected by your parents
and by the system?
But then something incredible happened.
See, my name?
I spent the millennium
searching for worthy champion
of the powers child
who fight for the world.
Hey, Khaleesi.
Yo, Shazam!
Fury of the Gods really beat you 13.
Welcome back, everyone is Charlie.
There's a brand new Shazam
Fury of the Gods trailer.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs
that will break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I know there's lots of questions
about how all
these characters figure into the big
DC Studios reboot in DC.
Phase one are DC, Chapter one is James
Gunn is calling it.
He's calling them chapters instead of
phases, but it's the same basic concept.
So as many of you know, DC has been
disconnected in film and television
for a long time, and it's one of,
you know, our jobs mine and Peter's
is to come in
and make sure the DCU is connected
in film, television, gaming and animation,
that the characters are consistent,
played by the same actors,
and it works within one story.
Now, Peter and I have gotten pretty lucky
in terms of the four projects
that are coming out over the next year.
First, we have Shazam Fury of the Gods.
Shazam has always been off
kind of in his own part of the DCU,
so he connects very well.
That moves directly into The Flash,
a fantastic movie
that I really love
that resets the entire DC universe.
Then to move into Blue Beetle,
a fantastic film about a kid
who's a marvelous part of the DCU,
and then into Aquaman two,
which leads directly
into our next few projects,
which I'm going to tell you about now.
Next up is the big one,
the true beginning of the DCU.
This is called Superman Legacy.
This is being written by me.
I'm in the middle of it.
I'm having a great time doing it.
And Superman will be released
into theaters July 11th, 2025.
Zachary Levi seems very confident
that he's going to come back.
James Gunn did say that the Flash movie
would reboot
most of the previous DCU,
but not completely reboot everything.
According to him,
it is possible that Gal Gadot comes back
as Wonder Woman and it is possible
that the Shazam characters come back.
But we know that the Rock
is not coming back as black.
Adam So like, not every single Shazam
associated character is coming back,
but they're still releasing
all the previous DCU connected movies
this year,
and some of them they're just saying, Oh,
this could be part of our new DCU,
they're just calling it
the DCU instead of the DCU.
The Blue Beetle
movie is a good example of that.
Like they said, when the Blue Beetle
movie comes out later, this year,
that could be part of their new DCU
as if it was going to be part of it
just because of the way they made
the movie to be relatively self-contained
and without too many overt
connections to the DCU.
Like not every single Justice
League member
like Henry Cavill, Superman shows up
and helps them out to the entire movie.
So from a practical perspective, it's just
easier for me to say, Oh, you know what?
This is connected
because we say it's connected.
And it seems like that's the tactic
they're taking with some of the movies
this year,
and that's why they're removing
some of the cameo scenes from DCU.
Actors like Henry Cavill, Superman
from The Flash movie.
In some of them they're keeping in in
some of the Post-Credits
scenes are changing, like,
can we make a couple edits to this
particular movie so that it feels like
it's less connected to the DCU
and more connected to our DCU
after the big reboot.
But it is helpful to know
that they are planning on doing what
we all kind
of assumed that they were going to do
and use the big flash point twist in
the Flash movie to soft reboot everything.
During the new Shazam
Fury of the Gods trailer,
it seems like it's mostly
about Billy believing in himself,
which gets into the origin
of their powers,
like the acronym that makes up
all the different names in their powers.
Shazam is an acronym
that stands for The Wisdom of Solomon.
The Strength of Hercules,
The Stamina of Atlas, The Power of Zuse.
The Courage of Achilles
in the Speed of Mercury Black.
Adam has the same thing for his name.
It's meant to be another
acronym of Shazam, but it represents
the Egyptian gods in Black Adam's case.
And in this case, it's the Greek gods.
There are a couple names in there, though,
that weren't
traditionally Greek gods, though,
so I think they're there
treating them like legendary figures.
Because if you look at this page
in the Book of Magic,
that's based on their powers, like this
is the one with the lightning on it
that symbolizes their powers.
It just seems like Mary Marvel finds
this book of magic in the Rock of Eternity
that was written by the Wizard Shazam
about the origin of their powers and
how he created them in the first place.
That's the whole thing with Helen Mirren's
character in the Three Sisters
that are trying to take the powers
back of the Greek Titan Atlas.
Some of the Greek mythology,
I think they're playing a little fast
and loose with they're treating them
like legendary figures.
Like technically, Atlas wasn't a God.
He was a Titan.
It's a slightly different thing,
but still just as powerful.
In the clip, Billie is in Shazam,
powered up form in adult form,
talking to his child therapist
because technically in the child,
he'd still be seeing a child
therapist played by P.J.
Byrne, who you probably recognize
from a thousand things.
He's actually been in a bunch of stuff
recently into just talking Billie
through all the traumatic things
in his past and how he's overcome that.
Since the events of the first movie
to become the character Shazam.
So in this trailer
and in the previous trailer
where it seems like
he's trying to give up his powers,
like, No, no, I need to sacrifice myself
in order to save Freddie Freeman.
Here.
He either pretends like he's
going to give up his powers
like he feigns in order
to get them to lower their defenses.
And then he has that knock down, drag out
fight with the dragon
after making a whole bunch of Game
of Thrones Khaleesi references.
It sounds like a lot of these scenes
in a lot of the movie,
maybe just in general, are him drawing
on the powers of the courage of Achilles.
Because in the first movie,
you mostly just see him using his powers
of flight strength lightning.
The lightning come from the power of Zeus.
Like that's what that power represents.
The strength of Hercules
is just like his physical strength.
The other interesting thing
that the director
said about the Dragon in the movie is that
the dragon is actually made of wood
from this mythical tree.
It seems like their home is on Mount
Olympus or somewhere near
Mount Olympus, just because we're talking
about the Greek mythology here.
There are a couple more scenes
inside there, like behind the sisters
on this altar.
Here you can see this
giant statue of their father,
the Greek titan
that was holding the earth.
When they say the wizard Shazam
stole the powers from their father.
And these are the people using the staff
here, like as is depicted,
you see all the different names around him
here.
It'll be interesting
to see how they explain this.
Did he really steal them
or was he granted the power or a portion
of the power by Atlas himself?
My only theory right now,
because Rachael Ziegler's
character, who's meant to represent
like the youngest sister,
seems like she sides with Freddie Freeman,
like she falls in love with him,
or they start some kind of relationship
and wants to help the Shazam.
Lee and her sisters turn against her
because you see her fighting her sisters
and her fighting the dragon
with Freddie Freeman.
Early theory
is that by the end of the movie
they'll come to an arrangement
where the sisters just grant them
a portion of their father's power.
So they continue to use their powers,
but they're not, quote unquote,
stealing it from the sisters anymore.
This also just gets into the idea
of how the Shazam in the black Adam
characters get their power.
They don't take all the power away
from the gods
that make up the names in their acronyms.
They just draw on the power.
The other interesting thing,
talking more about Wonder Woman mythology,
because this is Greek
mythology, it's the same group of gods,
the same group of titans
that we're talking about here.
During the trailer for James Gunn's
big reboot,
he released
I already did a big video for it,
so I'll post a link at the end of this
and down to the description below.
But as part of that,
one of the big HBO series
that they're doing is Paradise
Lost about the Amazons.
But it said before Wonder Woman was born.
So we're talking like 5000 plus years ago
when all the Greek
gods,
like Zeus in his family, were still alive.
So if you remember the flashback
to the Dark Side war 10,000 years ago
during the Justice League, Snyder cut,
We're probably going to be seeing way
more of those types of characters now.
Obviously, they're going to recast
a lot of those characters,
but it's just the idea that we're going
to see more with those gods before Wonder
Woman is born.
Like she'll probably be born
at the end of that series.
That's one of the primary reasons
why they canceled Wonder Woman three
Because if James Gunn is saying
that Gal Gadot
could come back as Wonder Woman,
they're probably just waiting
until they make it through this
first phase to bring her back.
As far as we know, though,
according to James Gunn's announcements
about the upcoming DCU projects,
the first major one is supposed to be
the new Superman Legacy movie.
Even though there are a couple of projects
here on the schedule
that will come before that.
The Superman Legacy movie
isn't supposed to be released until 2025,
so it sounds like there's
going to be a period after this year
where they're just kind of stuff in limbo
in-between things.
it sound like
there was going to be a Peacemaker
Season two as well, because the Amanda
Waller series is supposed to take place
between Peacemaker Season
one and Peacemaker Season two,
and it'll star some of the Peacemaker
characters, which was a DCU series
like some of his Suicide Squad
DCU characters are continuing,
but it looks like there aren't any Shazam
related movies involving those characters
or the Black Adam characters
during his official Phase one.
Look at Shazam Fury of the Gods
movie is the last time you'll see
any Shazam related characters
for a good long while.
So it's one of those deals
when Zachary Levi talking about coming
back is like will come back,
but it'd be like three or four years
before you might see those characters
again anywhere,
let alone in another one of their movies.
Also, one of the problems with that
is that if they do bring them back,
all the kids would be so much older,
they would look so much older
that it would get kind of weird.
Really good example is Mary Marvel.
The reason why she's being played
by the kid
version of the character
is because they aged up
so much in the couple of years
since the first movie
that she just looked like the perfect age
to play her character as an adult.
Asher Angel is 20 years old right now.
As we're releasing this movie in a couple
more years, like four more years, E.B.
in his mid-twenties,
he would be the perfect age,
theoretically,
to play a version of Shazam.
Now he's not super swole,
so it'll look kind of weird
that Diesel has CG above him up.
That's why I'm not holding my breath
on all the Shazam characters coming back.
The other big thing
we haven't been talking about
as much is the new Batman that they're
going to have in this shared DCU.
They're going to have two Batmen
going forward.
They'll be the Robert Pattinson Batman
in the Batman, too.
Matt Reeves is apparently just calling it
the Batman Part two right now.
That will also be coming out in 2025,
the same year that that new Superman
legacy movies coming out.
And as you can see on this chart,
it'll be an elseworlds
movie set in a different universe,
not connected to the DCU,
not connected to the Superman legacy
movie, for instance,
that Batman will be in The Brave
in the Bold movie
and it'll be a Damian Wayne Team-Up movie
with the rest of the bat-family.
So like skipping way further ahead,
like we have young Robert Pattinson,
Batman and like Batman, you're three
by the time Batman two comes out.
Then a little while after the Superman
Legacy movie will have Braven The Bold
with a young version of Damian Wayne
the Batman is already had.
I'm assuming he'll be in his forties.
We'll see how all they wind up making him
and we'll have Nightwing will have Red
Hood will have pretty much all the other
major members of the Bat-Family
kind of skipping over the development
of some of those characters.
He didn't say Bat-Family
so they'll all be in there somewhere.
I don't know if every single one of them
is going to be in the movie,
but when he was talking about
the comic books that were inspired,
he specifically spoke
about Grant Morrison's run
because he created Damian Wayne
in when he introduced the character.
That was actually when Nightwing
was wearing the Cape and the cow.
So he'll be kind of weird if they do
The Brave in the Bold movie with a version
of Batman and Damian Wayne in
They don't do Nightwing during that movie.
I'm sure there's going to be
a thousand questions
about all these different new movies
and all the reboot stuff that's happening.
Don't worry,
I'll do videos about everything.
And because we have the Super Bowl
trailers
that are dropping
in the next couple of days, there's
going to be a brand new flash trailer
with a whole bunch of different footage.
Of course
I'll do videos for all that stuff.
Be sure to enable alerts
so you don't miss any of that.
Everyone click here for that
much larger DC Studios trailer
for all the rebooted movies
and the new HBO series that they're doing,
and click here for my brand new Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania Video to watch
Kang Start the Cain Multiverse War.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.